-
>>Tina: My role in this project
is creating the prefabricated
building walls.
>>Brittany: I've been working with
the business aspect of the project.
>>Fabiana: I was in charge of
working on the water management.
>>Alasanne: My roles in
this project is based
on the energy system for the house.
>>Simon: Some kids take real
pride in having a 98 in red ink
with a smiley face
on a piece of paper.
But most of us, when you
think back to high school,
the things you remember
are not that test.
It's something real that you did.
And our question is, why
can't school be based on that?
>>You've got one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven boards that you need
to cut to make a wall.
Let's figure out, how long do we need
to cut all your two by fours, right?
>>Student: Mm-hmm.
>>Simon: The sustainability
workshop is a school program,
it's a high school program
for high school seniors.
The idea behind the program is that
students can actually learn more
by doing real world projects.
>>The big question that you always
get is, how are students going
to learn to read and do math if
they're working on projects all day?
And we thought the best
way to show people was
to create this pilot program
and demonstrate what it
looks like and feels like.
>>It's called Land Rafts and it's
a high efficiency, modular home.
These modular homes will be packaged
in a reused shipping container.
>>Inside the shipping container,
it is packed with composting
toilet, solar panels...
>>Prefabricated walls, battery packs.
>>A water kit system, energy system.
>>Basically, Land Raft is one package
that provides everything you need.
>>And this is to be deployed
in disastrous areas like Haiti.
>>Once it gets over there, they
will be able to pull it out
and put all the systems
together within two days.
>>Alasanne: Yeah, let's
bring all the other end too.
>>Simon: The students did a
tremendous amount of research
on Haiti, natural disasters.
A part of it that was
thrilling for me was this idea
that developing countries don't have
access to the sustainable technology.
When natural disasters occur in
these countries, there's this inrush
of money to address recovery
and wouldn't it be cool to use
that as a mechanism to deploy
these high efficiency, small homes?
>>To the best of our
ability, we need to make sure
that these are square, right?
Right now, look, this is
turned this way slightly.
>>They developed a business
plan and a technical report,
what kind of sustainable materials,
energy capture, water capture.
And so the research, the
science, the math and the kind
of research abilities that
they developed were impressive.
>>Tina: Okay, let's go back
in the shipping container
and see how much space we'll have,
if we do it like vertical wise
and horizontal wise, you
know what I'm saying?
>>Tina: My role in this project is
creating the prefabricated building
walls that can be fit inside
the shipping container.
>>There are going to be three here,
three panels here and
two panels here.
>>So we're creating about
eight panels for the walls,
eight panels for the ceilings
and four panels for the flooring.
>>Man: So here is the big question:
how do we get potential customers?
>>Brittany: I've been working with
the business aspect of the project,
basically trying to translate
the whole technical idea
and the good idea into
a real world project.
>>It has potential to rebuild
communities efficiently, so...
>>Man: Yeah, this is long term, this
is permanent, this is sustainable.
>>Brittany: So I've been looking
into where does the money go
and how does Land Rafts
fit into budgets
of nongovernmental organizations?
>>Sagar: So basically, I click on it
which will take me to other window
and then I can just go to sketch.
>>The part that I'm working
on with the Land Raft is
designing the whole structure
of the modular home on 3D AutoCAD,
and making an earthquake-proof
foundation.
>>We put the foundation and then
the flooring, then the walls.
>>I'm the kind of guy who likes to
work on graphics and stuff like that,
so I thought if I'm in this
project, I have to like,
I'm going to use the 3D AutoCAD
a lot, which I like to do.
>>Alasanne: We tried to test
the solar panels by putting five
of them together and put them
at the forty-five degree angle.
>>My roles in this project is based
on the energy system for the house.
>>This is where we were trying to
put the batteries and on this...
>>So we're using solar
panels that will be mounted
on the roof of the container.
We're also using twenty batteries
and the batteries' input will
be twenty kilowatts an hour.
>>Student: Your right
hand up, there you go.
>>No.
>>Yeah, that's right.
>>That's it.
>>That's correct.
>>Simon: The process of trying
to solve a problem is what
we're really after, right?
The solution doesn't
even really matter.
It's the fact that students are
struggling with real information.
They're taking ownership,
they're engaged.
And then the amount of
intellectual work that has to occur
to build an electric car or create a
Land Raft or create a business plan
that solves a lighting
problem is tremendous.
>>Student: All push.
Lift your hand, in the bottom.
>>Simon: Hold on.
>>William: A program
like Sustainability Workshop
is really important for us
as a school district, because
if you think about the skills
that our children need in
order to be competitive,
skills like problem solving, critical
thinking, collaboration, innovation,
then Sustainability workshop
provides those types of experiences.
And not only are they taking on
tough and challenging world problems,
there's been a tremendous amount
of learning that has taken place.
>>Simon: A lot of the school day in
a typical urban school is "Sit down,
be quiet, take your hat off,
put your cell phone away."
Here it's, "Why is that?
Why isn't that working?"
or "Why are you getting frustrated?"
And even the difficult
conversations are conversations
around stuff that's real,
instead of, "Behave,
please fall in line, comply."
>>That's one of the things I
think this process allows for,
and teachers that thrive
in it do really well,
is we see the best in these students.
We see the potential they
have, we really see it,
and it's not like I've got
high expectations for Johnny
and he's going to live up to them.
It's, "I know that you can do
this and we're here to work
on this together and
let's get it done."
>>All: One, two, three, Workshop!
All right [laughter].